ارهاق بدا يظهر على وجوههم نوبات بحث
متواصله انهكتهم فعلا لكن الاشد ارهاقا
تعاملهم مع العالقين تحت الركام ومن
ينتظرهم في الخارج
ثلاثه ايام من عمليات البحث كانت مهمات
عمال الانقاذ خلالها كثيره ولم تقتصر فقط
على الحفر سواء بالايدي او المعدات
هؤلاء كانوا حضنا لامهات واباء اثقلهم هم
الفقد وتحولوا كتفا تكئ عليها الجميع عند
وقوع الفاجعه الله يصبرنا فيكم يا ربي
دخيلك
قل لا اله الا الله
طمانه المنتظرين خارج المباني المدمره شيء
لكن ملاقاه اطفال لفهم الرعب لساعات وحتى
ايام شيء اخر
تكبير في البدايه نعم اي بعد سماع النفس
ورؤيه وجوه تتكلم تلهي دعابه او اي كلمه
قد تزيح عن مسرح طفولتهم مشاهد خوف وذعر
ولو للحظه كما يزاح الغبار المتراكم على
اجسادهم
يعمل
حكى
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بعد الانقاذ تبدا معاناه البحث عما يطفئ
اجساد الناجين وماوى يقيهم البرد لم يس
معني صركبسوا الماضي يلاحق عمال الانقاذ
السوريين صور حرب ارادوا مسحها من ذاكرتهم
بفعل تقدم السنين لكنها اليوم عادت وبشكل
اقصى